[Musique]
et le fait qu'un seul parti qui est
capable de regrouper aujourd'hui 1200
jeunes il est de nouveau en plein essor
les 4 et 5 septembre se tenait à port
marly le rendez vous de la jeunesse qui
rassemblait près de 1200 personnes
fort de ce grand succès pouvons
poursuivre la dynamique
maintenant pour intervenir encore plus
la bonne nous avons besoin de vous nous
avons besoin de votre énergie
proposant de vos propositions de décider
nous avons besoin des jeunes si vous
aussi passionné de politique vous
souhaitez défendre des convictions de
droite
pragmatique positive et ambitieuse pour
l'avenir de notre pays
oser franchir le cap et rejoignez nous
car c'est l'occasion parfaite de
participer à la dynamique de
revitalisation de la droite républicaine
sur laquelle nous sommes engagés depuis
la rentrée
si vous vous êtes jamais engagé en
politique auparavant n'hésitez pas
faites comme moi et comme nous tous aux
républicains franchissez le pas engager
vous aurais dit souvent qu emmanuel
macron est un président de droite
pourtant il a laissé la société se
fracturer la dette s'enflammer la
sécurité ne pas être une priorité du
gouvernement
il a beaucoup promis il a beaucoup déçu
mais il a surtout rompu la confiance
alors dans tout éléphants ton
département ta région rejoint les jeunes
républicains et rebâti son ensemble la
droite de demain franchissez le pas il
engagez vous engagez vous chez les
républicains
alors rejoignez nous sur les huit ans
rejoignent alors je vous propose
d'adhérer devraient adhérer aux
républicains pour construire ensemble la
france de demain
[Musique]